Greetings to my 3BN family and welcome
to another 3ABN Today Bible Q&A. I'm
Ricky Carter and I'll be your host.
We've got another hourpacked program
with your Bible questions and the Lord
has blessed us with the answers from his
word of which our panelist will be
sharing with us. So let me introduce you
to our panelists starting to my right
after have pastor John Denzy. Welcome
brother.
>> Thank you. It's a blessing to be here
and always enjoy looking at these
questions. We always learn something as
we go to the Lord in prayer and search
the scriptures.
>> Amen. Amen. And next to Pastor Denzy via
video chat, we have Pastor James
Rafferty. Welcome, Pastor.
>> Good to be here, Ricky. Pastor John
Denzy. Looking forward to God's
blessings and leadings as we seek to
answer the questions that have been sent
in by our viewers.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, great. Well, before we
actually get into our program, we need
to start off with a word of prayer.
Pastor Denzy, could you lead us in
prayer, please?
>> Yes. It's important. Let's go to the
Lord in prayer.
>> Amen.
>> Our marvelous and wonderful heavenly
father, we thank you, Lord, for the holy
scriptures.
>> Thank you so much that they are a light
for us in this world of darkness,
>> in this world of wickedness. we find
hope and encouragement and we thank you
Lord that we can trust in you and we can
understand the scriptures as you bless
us with the Holy Spirit. So we ask for
the blessing of the Holy Spirit upon us,
Pastor James, myself and brother Ricky
and all those that are listening
wherever they are. Help them to
understand these things. And we ask Lord
that as we share this will draw us close
to you. We ask you in the holy and
blessed name of Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Well, viewers, before we give us give
out the first question, let's I want to
remind you how you can participate at
home with 3ABN Today Bible Q&A. There's
one of three ways that you can do so.
You can email us your questions to
Bible QA3ABN.tv.
That's bibleabn.tv.
or you can text us your questions to
618-2283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
And then for those of you who are on
Instagram, you can send us your
questions in that way at 3ABN official
at 3ABN official. All right, Pastor
James, I've got your first question.
>> Okay,
>> here we go.
If the scriptures forbid the wearing of
jewelry, why does Ezekiel 16 11-2
use imagery of bracelets, a chain, a
nose jewel, and earrings to describe God
adorning his people? Couldn't this
passage be used to justify wearing
jewelry today? That's from Bernard in
Jamaica who emailed that to us.
>> Thank you, Bernard. Appreciate that
question. Yes, absolutely agree with
you. It could be used to justify wearing
jewelry by some. Uh however, the context
is actually speaking about the wealth
that is given to God's people as a
nation, not individual people.
>> And we see this also in the New
Testament book of Revelation chapter 17,
for example. There a woman is decked out
with jewelry. Let's read a few of those
verses. Ezekiel chapter, excuse me,
Revelation 17, uh verses 1-6.
And there came one of the seven angels,
which had the seven vials, and talk with
me, saying unto me, "Come hither, and I
will show thee the judgment of the great
that sits upon many waters, with
whom the kings of the earth have
committed fornication, and the
inhabitants of the earth have been made
drunk with the wine of her fornication."
So he carried me away in the spirit into
the wilderness, and I saw a woman sit
upon a scarlet-c colored beast, full of
names of blasphemy, having seven heads
and 10 horns. And the woman was arrayed
in purple and in scarlet. And there was
a golden cup in her hand, full of
abominations, and the filthiness of her
fornication. And upon her head, a
forehead her a name was written,
mystery, Babylon the great, the mother
of harlots, the abominations of the
earth. And I saw the woman drunken with
the blood of the saints and with the
blood of martyrs of Jesus. And when I
saw her, I wondered with great
admiration.
So you see this woman is color is
covered with purple and scarlet. She's
decked with gold and precious stones and
pearls.
Here though, much like the vision in
Ezekiel, these texts are describing a
church, which is often symbolized as a
woman in the scriptures. And the jewelry
and the costly array that she's wearing
symbolizes her wealth, which is also
what God is doing in Ezekiel's vision of
the woman that's decked with jewelry.
But in Revelation, the adorning of the
woman of the church is actually an
indication of adultery, of her falling
away from God, of apostasy. Now in
Ezekiel, the adorning of God's church
led them to apostasy. In other words,
God blessed them. That was the symbolism
there of the jewelry and gold etc. But
these precious blessings
actually led her into apostasy. Uh
likewise, Lucifer is identified in
Ezekiel 28:12-14.
And in these scripture references, he's
decked out by God with precious stones,
etc. And in all three of these
references, we see that Julie leads
God's creation into deeper apostasy.
>> Now, in contrast, and likely because of
this, God gives us a picture of his
church in the last days without being
clothed with jewelry, but being clothed
with the sun, which represents the
righteousness of Jesus Christ according
to Malachi 4:2, and standing on the
moon, which represents the word of God
according to Psalm 119,
um, verse 105.
and having a crown of 12 stars which
represent those who lead people to Jesus
according to Daniel 12 and:e3.
So this appearance of this great wonder
in heaven in revelation 12 clothed with
a sun, the moon under her feet and a
crown of 12 stars is in a way confirms
that God has taken the jewelry off his
church. He's removed it from his church
because consistently when Christians
begin to adorn themselves with gold and
silver and precious things, it's a sign
they are putting off the adornment of
Christ as noted in those Bible verses.
So then we have this final council. 1
Peter 3:1.
Likewise ye wives be subjection to your
husbands, that if any obey not the word
of God, they may also be without the
word one by the conversation of their
wives, while they behold your chase
conversation, coupled with fear, whose
adorning, let it not be that of the
outward adorning, the plating of hair,
wearing of gold, putting on of apparel,
but let it be the hidden man of the
heart, which is not corruptible, the
ornament of a meek and quiet spirit, the
Bible says, which in the sight of God is
of great Christ for after this manner um
the of old time the women the holy women
of old time who trust in God adorn
themselves being in subjection to their
own husbands. So God is basically saying
here that let's put off the outward
adorning especially if you're married to
an unbeliever.
>> Let's put off the outward adorning.
Let's have that meek and quiet spirit.
That's the adorning of the Old and New
Testament of God's people who are
faithful to him and didn't go into
apostasy. Amen. Hope that helps answer
the question, Bernard. Amen. Amen. Thank
you very much, Pastor James. All right,
Pastor Denzy, here's your first
question.
What does it mean to reign as priests
with Jesus during the 10,000 years? The
Bible says we will be judging, but what
does it mean to be priests for him? And
that was sent to us by a text message.
>> Thank you so much. Uh yes, you have uh
revelation chapter 20 that talks about
judging and uh I want to point to you
some scriptures that help us a little
bit understanding about priest. In
Exodus chapter 19 uh we start in verse
5. It says, "Now therefore, if you will
indeed obey my voice and keep my
covenant, then you shall be a special
treasure to me above all people, for all
the earth is mine, and you shall be to
me a kingdom of priests and a holy
nation. These are the words which you
shall speak to the children of Israel."
So God here is talking to Moses and
tells him that the people of Israel were
going to be be to him a kingdom of uh
priests. And so it's interesting. So
that meant though all the people in
essence were a kingdom of priest to who?
Well to the other people. They were to
minister to other people. Help them to
learn about God. But you as you see
later on in the scriptures it says all
shall know me. So this is in essence
something interesting to consider as we
go into Revelation chapter 1 and verse 5
and six. Notice what we have here. And
from Jesus Christ the faithful witness
the firstborn from the dead and the
ruler over the kings of the earth. To
him who loved us and washed us from our
sins in his own blood and has made us
kings and priests. To his God and
father. To him be glory and dominion
forever and ever. Amen. So we have an
interesting development here as we see
that John is saying he's made us
priests. Why? Uh because as you see the
development of the Bible is that in
essence the believers are priests that
we offer prayer. We offer to the Lord
our lives as a sacrifice. Not that we
kill ourselves but our life as an
offering to God to serve him. This is
why I now go to first Peter chapter 2 uh
verse 9 and 10. Notice what uh is
written here for us. But you are a
chosen generation, a royal priesthood, a
holy nation, his own special people,
that you may proclaim the praises of him
who called you out of darkness and into
his marvelous light. So this is one of
the reasons that you become um a priest.
You proclaim the praises of him who
called you out of darkness into his
marvelous light. Notice verse 10. who
once were not a people but are now the
people of God who had not obtained mercy
but now have obtained mercy. This is
obviously talking to people that are
that are not Jews. Now you're a chosen
generation. Now you're a royal
priesthood so that you can offer praises
to our loving God. So when we go uh to
as we consider these things uh the
believers are priests in that sense and
this is why you see also in revelation
chapter 20 that we are given the
privilege to judge and go through the
books and it's an interesting concept to
to understand the essence of a priest.
What is a priest? A priest is someone
dedicated to God, separated to God for
uh service to God. And so and that's why
all the believers can be considered as
priests.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you very much, Pastor
Denzy. All right, Pastor James, I've got
your second question.
What happened when Jesus breathed on the
disciples and told them to receive the
Holy Spirit, giving them the authority
to forgive sins or withhold forgiveness?
How is this giving of the Holy Spirit
different from that different from what
was promised in Acts 1:es 4 and 5 and
what occurred later in Acts chapter 2:es
1-4?
That's from Mvin who emailed that to us.
>> Great question, Mvin. Thank you. Just
wanted to comment on what Pastor John
just said. You know, I never picked that
up before. That's such a a key point
that priesthood means proclaiming God's
goodness, which we'll be able to do
throughout the eternal ages, sharing the
goodness of God with uh all the unfallen
worlds and our experience on planet
Earth with the only uh planet that
apostaside from God. Good question.
Really good question. You know, this
question has been one that I've wrestled
with for many years. I was raised
Catholic and this question is used uh in
the Catholic church to support the idea
that we should confess our sins uh to
priests to people to men and not
directly to God. So when we look at this
we understand that the former Holy
Spirit uncction was given primarily that
is the uncction in John chapter 20 we'll
read those verses was given primarily
for administrative function. Um the the
latter outpouring of the Holy Spirit in
Acts chapter 1 and Acts chapter 2 was uh
given um primarily for increase in
preaching and teaching and healing in
power. Right? So John chapter 20 21-23
says this. Then Jesus said to them again
peace be unto you. As my father has sent
me even so I send you. This is kind of
like the great commission. And when he
had said this, he breathed on them and
said unto them, receive ye the Holy
Ghost. Whosoever sins you remit, they
are remitted unto them. And whosoever
sins you retain, they are retained. Now
in the Bible, there are at least three
levels of forgiveness. We want to look
at this carefully. The first one is
personal forgiveness. And that
forgiveness is a forgiveness that takes
place between us and God individually.
The second is personal individual
forgiveness between human beings. That
is when you forgive somebody else or
they forgive you for something you've
done against them or vice versa. The
third level of forgiveness is a
corporate or administrative forgiveness
made by the church toward its members
who may or may not need to be
disciplined. Now the personal
forgiveness can only take place between
one human being and God through Jesus
Christ. That's what we're told in 1 John
1 9-2,
1 Timothy 2:5, Matthew 6:12.
The personal individual forgiveness
between humans can take place when we
forgive another person who has sinned
against us. And we see that in Matthew 6
14 and 15, and Ephesians 4:32 and 2
Corinthians 2:7. Now even though we may
do this, the person who has sinned still
needs to pursue personal individual
forgiveness directly with God. So we can
forgive other people but that sin still
needs to be forgiven by God
individually. Now the corporate
forgiveness which is what John 20:23 is
talking about is the one the church
offers often in a form of discipline. So
for those who have sinned in a way that
has been made public and needs public
restitution. This third type of
forgiveness is what's spoken about in
Matthew chap 18 verses 15 to18 along
with John chapter 20 and verse 23. Now
even though this is the strongest
argument John 20:23 is the strongest
argument used by Catholics to try to
support the idea that priests can
forgive sins like Jesus did. This is not
talking about the idea of a
confessional. That's not even in the
Bible. Nowhere in the Bible do we have
the idea of a confessional. It is
speaking of the authority of church
leadership to discipline its members
>> in Matthew 18:15 to18. It describes the
same teaching. It's an authority given
to the church leaders. That's why Jesus
gave it to the apostles to make
decisions regarding sins that are
committed among the members. And notice
this also the verse says whosoever sins
you retain, they are retained. This then
shows that this verse is not talking
about forgiveness only. It's also
talking about the church judgment
regarding issues that arise among the
church members that need to be dealt
with and that is to be designated by the
Holy Spiritfilled church leadership. And
there going to be times when they can
remit and there going to be times when
they're retained based on whether or not
the persons involved are repentant,
truly repentant of their sins. So I hope
this helps to answer that question.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, Pastor James.
All right, Pastor Dy. Here's your second
question.
What happened after the wilderness
sanctuary was moved? Was the most holy
reconsecrated with sacrificial blood or
was the ark simply placed and built
around? That was a question sent to us
via YouTube.
>> That is a very good question and I see
good thinking there uh bringing up this
question. Uh yes. Uh during the time of
the wilderness tabernacle and the
journeying of the people of Israel for
about 40 years, they moved several times
and they didn't move whenever they
wanted to. They moved whenever the
pillar of cloud that was with them
started moving and they that's when they
started moving and they picked they
picked up everything very carefully
handling all the instruments all of the
vessels and everything very carefully
and uh carrying it and packing it
according to the instruction of the
Lord. Uh there is no indication in the
Bible that says they had to reconsecrate
the most holy place when it was moved.
There is no indication in the Bible. Uh
when they moved, they carried the ark on
their shoulders and this was carried
very carefully and the tribe of uh Levi
was assigned to carry the ark of the
covenant and the holy furnishings. But
uh they were not allowed to touch the
ark. So this was handled with poles
because it was considered holy. And
remember that uh there was a time when
they were traveling and it appeared as
it was about to fall and somebody
>> tried to steady it and unfortunately
died because they're not supposed to
touch with human hands because we're
sinners. Uh so not even the priests were
allowed to do that. Now, it's
interesting that we have here um
in uh Exodus chapter 40, and I'd like to
read that uh when it was installed
uh it says here
uh Exodus 40 beginning in verse 16, thus
Moses did according to all that the Lord
had commanded him. So, he did. And it
came to pass in the first month of the
second year on the first day of the
month that all that the tabernacle was
raised up. So Moses raised up the
tabernacle and fastened his sockets, set
up its boards, put it in his bars, and
raised up the pillars, and he spread out
the tent over the tabernacle and put the
covering of the tent on top of it as the
Lord had commanded Moses. The same thing
had to happen in when they moved. He
took the testimony and put it into the
ark, and it was already in the ark. They
didn't take it out uh when they moved.
Inserted the post through the rings of
the ark and put the mercy seat on top of
it. And he brought the ark into, this is
the part we want to get to, into the
tabernacle, hung up the veil of the
covering, and positioned off the ark of
the testimony as the Lord had commanded
him. Everything had to be done according
to the way the Lord commanded. Now, um,
when we see the time of the day of
atonement, this is when you can see that
there was a, let's call it a, like you
said, a reconsecration of the most holy
place in essence. Uh, but when they
moved, there's no record. When they
moved, it is um, uh, about 40 times.
There is a reference to this in numbers
uh, chapter 4. You can see some of the
information about them moving, but there
is no information in the Bible about
them having to make sacrifices to
reconsecrate the ark of the covenant and
the most holy place.
>> Okay. Thank you, sir. Thank you very
much. All right. Well, Pastor James,
I've got your third question, but before
I give that to you, let me remind our
viewers how they can participate.
Friends, you can participate in one of
three ways. You can send us your
questions by email to bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
Or you can text us your questions to
618-2283975.
You can text the number again to
618-228-3975.
And then for those of you who are on
Instagram, you can send us your
questions in at 3ABN official. 3ABN
official. All right, Pastor James,
here's your third question.
Is there any connection between the
seven churches and the seven days of
creation? And that's from Norine who
emailed that to us.
>> Great question, Norin. You have actually
asked a question that has to do with my
favorite book of the Bible, which is the
book of Revelation.
>> So, yeah, the creation week suggests
that the number seven actually
represents completeness or perfection.
You know, God completed his work in six
days. He rested on the seventh day
because his work was complete. It was
perfect. It was very good. So this
number then is found throughout the book
of revelation. For example, we have
seven churches, seven seals, seven
trumpets, seven vials, seven thunders,
seven kings. Uh in this sense, the
number seven is also symbolic of
completeness. The seven churches, for
example, they're a symbol of God's
complete church, right? The complete
church of God. They're not just seven
literal churches. This number tells us
that the messages given to the seven
churches belong to all of God's churches
throughout all of time. Uh the messages
are God's complete and perfect message
to his churches from the apostolic age
all the way down to the second coming of
Jesus Christ. And we actually see this
in the council and the names given to
the churches. For example, Ephesus uh is
a church full of works
and great uh labor for God uh do having
patience and faith and trying those that
say they're apostles and are not and
found them liars, but they're in danger
of losing their first love. And that
definitely described the early church
who was on fire for Jesus. was that but
as time went on and some of the early
pioneers apostles disciples passed to
rest it began to move away from the love
of Christ and started moving more to the
emphasis of doctrine and theology. Uh
and then of course you have the
Leodysian church the last church that
word means people judged and this is a
people that feel spiritually rich in
need of nothing and they live in the
judgment hour. Revelation 14:7 talks
about the hour of God's judgment coming
and leadya is the church of the judgment
hour. So definitely we see a correlation
between uh the meaning of the number
seven. Uh it means complete and perfect
and it connects to revelation uh because
revelation uses the number seven again
and again because this book in a sense
is God's complete or perfect or final
message to the world. Um, we see this in
another example. The second coming of
Jesus is one of the main emphasis of the
book of revelation. And of course, God
is seeking to prepare people for the
second coming of Christ so we can be
ready to go to heaven with him.
>> And that second coming is emphasized in
the book of Revelation. Guess how many
times? Seven times. In fact, when you
start the book of Revelation, it's right
there, right at the beginning.
Revelation 1:7. And behold, he comes
with clouds, and every eye shall see
him. And then it moves on to the seven
churches and the seven seals. The seven
seals end with the second coming of
Jesus. That's twice. And then we go to
the seven trumpets. The seven trumpets
end with the second coming of Jesus.
That's three times. And then we go to
what we understand to be the three
angels messages in Revelation 12:1, 13,
and 14. And that closes with the second
coming of Jesus. That's what, four
times. And then we have the
uh the seven vials. And they actually
end with the second coming of Jesus. And
then we have Revelation chapter 19. And
that has a picture of the second coming
of Jesus. And I'm not keep I'm losing
track now. Oh yeah. And then we get to
the end of the book and that has a
picture of the second coming. Jesus
says, "Behold, I come quickly and my
reward is with me." I think that's
seven. But anyway, seven second
comingings in the book of Revelation.
Why is Jesus coming seven times? No. The
number seven means complete or perfect.
It's just emphasizing this final
complete and perfect message of God in
the book of Revelation.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you for pointing that
out. Yes. Yes. Okay, Pastor Denzy,
here's your third question.
When was the book of Revelation written?
Was it written before or after 70 AD? I
always believe that it was written on
the island of Patmas when John was old
and exiled. That's from Maurice in
Belgium who emailed that to us. Thank
you, Maurice. A good question again. And
uh it is very interesting question
actually. Uh there are some that believe
that it was written before 70 AD. And
it's interesting when you start looking
into this and you start reading this and
that to find out information. you know,
this idea of finding the date, uh, you
have to consider evidence from the Bible
>> and evidence from history to be able to
get an idea of when this could have
been. And so some have come to the
conclusion that it was before 70 AD
because they see uh some scriptures that
make them believe that because of the
persecution going on during the time of
Nero, the reign of Nero that perhaps it
was written uh before 70 AD
>> but there was also persecution under the
mission and that's after 90 after AD90.
So as you compare these things uh you
have to ask yourself what evidence is
there to help us understand. Uh so it's
interesting that the early Christian
writers as they looked at these things
most of them as they wrote said some
things that help us to understand for
example usbius
uh records that John was sent to Patmas
by the mission and that when those who
had been unjustly banished by the
mission were released by his successor
uh that's around uh AD
95 96 98 uh that's we can see a time
that
the AD 9095 in that arena is when the
book of revelation was written. Uh so uh
these testimonies lead us to believe
that it was around AD 96 when the book
of revelation was written. So what do we
do with all of this? I mean, is that is
that something that's going to
shake our faith if it was 70 AD before
70 AD or 90? No, not really. Uh per it
has historical value. It helps us to
understand that God is in control of all
things. But um it it has no great
reason. It says, "For what reason is it
important to know that it was written
before after 70 AD?" uh perhaps in the
context of looking at these things and
that God showed to John the things that
were shortly to come to pass as it says
uh there in the uh book of revelation uh
right around chapter one. So um we see
that it has not great importance in the
sense of that we have to look at the
Bible and what is there for us that
lights our pathway and that helps us
understand that God is in control of all
things. Things are going to happen
according to what we see in the
scriptures and book of revelation and
the book of Daniel especially the book
of revelation sheds a light for us to
help us understand where we are in
history and how soon the Lord Jesus
Christ is coming. So praise the Lord for
the book of revelation. Uh and it is a
revelation and some people think it's a
mystery that we cannot be understood. Uh
one of the programs that we point people
to is salvation and signs and symbols.
Pastor James Rafferty participated in
that and uh a good program to to to
listen to watch so that you can get a
better understanding of the book of
Revelation.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you very much Pastor
Lindsay. Yes. It's It's great to know
that God has everything under control.
All right, Pastor James, I've got your
fourth question. It's a long one.
After God created the earth and declared
it very good, he told Adam and Eve to be
fruitful and multiply, fill the earth,
and subdue it. After the fall, they were
banished from the garden. If the whole
earth was perfect, where did the area
outside the garden come from? Was the
earth created with two parts, the
perfect garden and a less perfect
outside? How long did the garden exist
after their banishment? And what
happened to it? Could Adam and Eve go
outside the garden before the fall?
That's from Santi in South Africa who
emailed that to us.
>> Well, there's a lot of questions in that
one question. Great uh great question,
Santi. Appreciate that. So yes, uh the
entire earth was perfect and good.
That's what we're told in Genesis,
right? That's the account of the Genesis
story that everything God made was very
good. That included the whole earth. All
right? The garden was simply part of the
earth. And the way into the garden was
blocked by two angels after the fall of
mankind because we became sinners. And
God did not want us to have access to
the tree of life as sinners. We read
about this in Genesis 3:es 22 to 24.
Let's take a look. And God said,
"Behold, the man is become as one of us
to know good and evil. And now, lest he
put forth his hand and take also of the
tree of life and eat and live forever."
Therefore, the Lord God sent him forth
from the Garden of Eden to till the
ground from whence he was taken. So he
drove out the man and placed at the east
of the garden of Eden cherubam with
flaming swords which turned every way to
keep the way of the tree of life. So
apparently there was an entrance to the
garden and that entrance was blocked and
those flaming swords, whatever they
were, were turning every single way so
that mankind could not have entrance
into the garden because mankind was not
to be given access to the tree of life.
That was a part of God's creation, but
the rest of God's creation was still
available to Adam and Eve.
>> Uh it only became worsened because of
sin. And we know this because eventually
God brought a flood of waters upon the
earth. So what happened to the garden?
Well, as far as we know, the garden
stayed in place. It was there. It was
just that God did not want mankind to
have access to the tree of life because
it was the tree of life that gave us
immortality. And this helps us to
understand that man is not naturally
immortal. In fact, only God is immortal.
We're told in the Bible, 1 Timothy
chapter 6. So we need to recognize this
is important. Only God has immortality
naturally as part of who he is. Every
one of his creatures receive immortality
from God and mankind receive that
immortality through the tree of life.
>> And we cannot have access to that tree
of life, that immortality as sinners.
>> Remember God said to Adam and Eve, "In
the day that you eat thereof, you shall
surely die."
>> So immortality came through the tree of
life. And again, immortality will come
to us through the tree of life. So, what
happened to the tree of life? Well, we
know that it probably stayed on planet
Earth at least until the flood. And
during the flood, of course, the whole
world was covered. Everything was
destroyed. Nothing was left. It it
appears that God may have taken the
garden itself back to heaven, or I
shouldn't say back to heaven, but to
heaven.
>> Because look at what we read about in
Revelation 22 and verse 14. It says
here, "And blessed are they that do his
commandments, that is the ten
commandments of God, that they may have
right to the tree of life and enter in
the gates into the city."
>> So entering into the city, we're going
to find the tree of life. We're going to
find
perhaps the garden of Eden there
according to Revelation 22 and:e14.
We're going to have access again to that
tree of life. And that access is going
to again allow us to live forever.
Immortality is granted to us. This
corruption puts on incorruption. This
mortality puts on immortality through
our access to the tree of life. The
fruit of that tree is transfor is
changed to different types of fruit uh
every month. And is it every 12 months?
No, it's every month. And we partake of
the tree of life. Now I don't know how
often we have to partake of the tree of
life. I know daily we need to partake of
food to sustain ourselves in our
physical life. So perhaps every month we
need to partake of the tree of life to
sustain our immortality.
>> Amen. Amen. I love how you used
Revelation 22:14 to to show that the
where the tree of life is currently.
That was great. Thank you for sharing
that. All right, Pastor Denzy, here's
your fourth question.
Can someone go straight to hell before
the end times judgment? That's from Mike
in Michigan who emailed that question to
us.
>> That's a very interesting question. You
know, I know that sometimes people have
a hard time with other people and they
want there are people being sent to hell
every day, I guess you can say, because
of issues going on uh in the sense of
they want them to go to hell. But
according to the Bible, the idea of
going to hell is not something that
happens right away. Some people think
that when you die, uh if you were good,
you go to heaven. If you were bad, you
go to hell. And so, what does the Bible
say about these things? I may dedicate a
little more time here uh in this
question. Uh considering the other
questions, uh let's go first to uh 1
Thessalonians. No, no, let's go first to
1 Corinthians chapter 15. 1 Corinthians
chapter 15. Let's go to verse 51. Notice
what it says here. Behold, I tell you a
mystery. We shall not all sleep, but we
shall all be changed. He's talking about
death here. We We're not We're not all
going to die. We will all be changed. In
a moment, in the twinkling of an eye, at
the last trumpet, well, when is that?
For the trumpet will sound,
and the dead will be raised
incorruptible, and we shall be changed.
is talking about the Christians, the
believers at this point. And it says,
"For this corruptible must put on
incorruption, and this mortal must put
on immortality." We are mortal. There's
nothing in the human being that is
immortal. We are mortal.
>> So when this corruptible has put on
incorruption, and this mortal has put on
immortality, then shall be brought to
pass the saying that is written, "Death
is swallowed up in victory. Oh death,
where is your sting? Oh, where is your
victory? The sting of death is sin and
the strength of sin is the law. But
thanks be to God who gives us the
victory through our Lord Jesus Christ.
>> So we have the victory through Jesus
Christ. This idea of um going to hell is
something that happens after the
millennium, after the 10,000 years for
the wicked. Uh this is why now I bring
you to um let's go to John chapter 5.
John chapter 5 verse 28 and 29. Notice
what Jesus says. Do not marvel at this
for the hour is coming in which all who
are in the grace will hear his voice. So
the hour has not come
>> right.
>> The hour comes when Jesus comes
>> uh for the believers. But the wicked,
they come from the grave at the
resurrection of damnation, which is
after the thousand years. Uh you can go
to Revelation chapter 20 and see uh
details about that. We may we're going
to try to read a few verses if we have
time. Notice what it says in John 5:29.
And it says uh well, finishing up once
again, pick up the the thread of
thought. Do not marvel at this. For the
hour is coming in which all who are in
the graves will hear his voice and come
forth. Those who have done good to the
resurrection of life and those who have
done evil to the resurrection of
condemnation.
That's the one where people are sent to
hell. So the idea is is it possible for
someone to go straight to hell without
uh the end time judgment? No. No. Uh it
says in Matthew 12:36, "But I say to you
that every idle word that men shall
speak, they shall give account thereof
in the day of judgment." That is in the
future. Revelation chapter 20, we we
Revelation 20, uh beginning in verse 11,
then I saw a great white throne and him
who sat on it from the whose face the
earth and the heaven fled away, and
there was found no place for them. And I
saw the dead, small and great, standing
before God, and books were opened. And
another book was open, which is the book
of life. And the dead were judged
according to their works by the things
which are written in the books. These
things are written in the books.
>> The good things and the bad things are
written in the books. Now, the
interesting thing is that the books are
opened and people are judged according
to their works. The righteous, their
record of evil deeds are wiped clean.
>> Amen.
>> By the blood of Jesus Christ. Because we
understand that the judgment of the
righteous that have passed away and
eventually leading to the judgment of
the living began in 1844.
>> So if the judgment of the of the
righteous began in 1844, that means that
when Jesus comes, their record is
already wiped clean. So when these these
books are open here uh they are done
they're open by the things they have
done the only thing remaining for the
righteous the good deeds and they uh
they are in the book of life the wicked
are not in the book of life and it says
here it says according to the things
they have done verse 12 now verse 13 the
sea gave up the dead who were in and
death and hes delivered up the dead who
were in them and they were judged each
one according to his works then death
and Hes were cast into the lake of fire.
This is the second death. And anyone not
found written in the book of life was
cast into the lake of fire. That's when
people go to hell. And this this uh
place, the lake of fire, what are people
doing there? They're not having fun.
They're not enjoying life. Uh so they
are burning. But the Bible says that the
wages of sin is death. So eventually
>> they die. They die.
>> Yes.
>> Amen. Thank you very much, Pastor Denzy.
>> All right,
I got your final question, Pastor James.
Can you clarify the use of wine and
strong drink in the Bible? Some say
Jesus drank wine or beer, and others
refer to Deuteronomy 14 26. How should
we understand this? That's from Yousef
in Tanzania who emailed that to us.
>> Thank you, Ysef from Tanzania. Great
question. And of course there are, you
know, several considerations that will
help us to navigate this topic, you
know, drinking alcohol, at least from a
biblical perspective. So let's look at a
few of those. Number one, we need to
realize that the Bible contains many
texts that prohibit the use of
intoxicating drink such as Leviticus 10
8-11, Proverbs 23:es 29-35.
But number two, the Bible contains many
texts that describe wine as a blessing,
such as Genesis 27:28,
Psalm 104:es 14 and 15. So number three,
both the Hebrew and the Greek words for
wine, yayen, Hebrew and onos can refer
in Greek can refer either to unfermented
grape juice which is affirmed by the
Bible or fermented grape juice which is
prohibited by the Bible according to
Proverbs 20:1 and Ephesians 5:18. Number
four, the Bible both prohibits and
commends the use of wine depending on
whether it is fermented or unfermented.
And that is without contradiction since
unfermented wine is hugely different
than fermented wine. 2 Timothy 3:16. In
other words, there's no contradiction
when Bible verses say, "Oh, you should
drink wine." And then other verses say,
"Oh, you shouldn't drink wine." There's
no contradiction because the point is is
that when it's talking about wine that
shouldn't be eaten drunk, it's
unfermented. And when it's talking about
wine that can be drank, it's excuse me,
when it's talking about wine that cannot
be drunk, it's fermented. And when it's
talking about wine that can be drunk,
it's unfermented wine. So number five,
true biblical temperance actually
requires the judicial use of that which
is good and complete abstinence from
that which is not good. And we can see
that in in uh Exodus 15:26 and 1st Peter
2:1. Let me just emphasize that point.
Even that which we are allowed to
partake of as in food and drink, we
should partake of temperantly. In
temperance itself is prohibited in the
Bible. Never mind partaking of things
that are not good for our bodies. So
this last point is really significant.
We're just going to spend some time on
this. You know, if we understand that
the Bible teaches that temperance and
eating and drinking that which is good
is allowed by God, but complete
abstinence from that which is not good.
Then we will recognize that anything
that God encourages us to drink or that
he himself blesses is referring to
something that is unfermented.
Especially when it comes to wine. With
wine, it would be unfermented grapes,
not fermented or alcoholic grapes. God
would never put his blessing on
something that is fermented or alcoholic
if he allow would allow us to drink it.
So, and even again the overuse of good
food is prohibited in the Bible. So, you
can imagine if the overuse of good food
is prohibited in the Bible, then how
much more any use of that which isn't
good for us.
>> And if you want to get an example of
this uh overuse of good uh food
prohibited in the Bible, you can read 1
Corinthians chap 11. Actually, let's
look at those verses. 1 Corinthians
11:es
20 and 21 say this. It's talking about
the Lord's supper and coming together
with to partake of the Lord's supper,
which is something we're commanded to do
in the Bible. It says, "When you come
together," Paul's speaking here,
"Therefore,
in one place, this is not to eat the
Lord's supper. For in eating, every one
of you takes before other his own
supper, and one is hungry, and the other
is drunken." Okay? So what he's saying
here is when you're coming together for
this Lord's supper, you're not really
coming together for the Lord's supper.
You're coming together to get drunk on
food, good food, food that's allowed,
and you're not allowing other people who
need some food to eat because you're
eating it all. You're consuming it all.
Right?
>> So this is a major point regarding I
think regarding alcohol, alcoholic
drinks in the Bible. God saved people,
it says, and this is Ephesians 5:18, are
to be filled with the Holy Spirit, not
drunk with wine on as noted in the
following verse. Notice what it says
here. Ephesians 5:18, be not drunk with
wine, where is in is wherein is excess,
but be filled with the spirit.
>> Here you have a contrast. Don't fill
yourself with wine. Don't fill yourself
to excess even with good food because
that can make you drunken. And it can it
can have an intoxicating influence on
you. Fermentation can actually take
place in our bodies in our stomachs
without the use of fermented food ahead
of time. We can put so much food in
there that it will ferment within us and
cause us to have be in a in a stuper of
sorts. Right? So don't don't do that.
Don't overeat. Don't be drunken with
even good food. Never mind fermented
food that's already fermented. But be
filled with the spirit. Now the Greek
word for excess is assotia which means
unsavoredness. Therefore this verse
could actually read be not drunk with
wine wherein is unsavoredness but be
filled with the spirit. And again that's
Ephesians 5 and verse 18. So we get the
idea from the Bible and that that food
is to help our mind stay clear and sharp
and be able to to think and to process
to have spiritual discernment of all
times. So we need to eat in a way that
keeps our mind sharp, right? And that we
don't get dull and tired and you know
because in those kinds of states of
mind, we often do things we wouldn't
normally do if we were sharp and clear
and able to process and to think. So
this is God's purpose for us. It's it's
it was God's purpose for the priest in
the Old Testament and it is still his
purpose in the New Testament priesthood
of believers. Right? And if you'd like
more uh a more detailed study on this
subject because it it there's a lot more
to it, uh you can email me
james.raferty3abn.org
and I can send you a a longer more uh
detailed study on the the use of wine in
the Bible.
>> Amen. Amen. Pastor James, yes. Thanks
for also including about the overeating
part as well,
>> right? All right, Pastor Denzy, here's
your final question. I keep noticing the
number 11 everywhere on clocks, TV, and
more. What biblical significance might
this have? Or why might I be seeing it
so often? That's from Jennifer in South
Carolina who emailed that to us.
>> Uh, thank you so much. It's very
interesting to me that you're looking
for a spiritual significance into this.
Uh, because the great majority of the
people when they start seeing certain
numbers, they think they have to play
that number in the lottery. And so, uh,
it's good to see that. It's refreshing.
Let's say, uh, when we look at this, we
have to ask ourselves, is really God
trying to tell you something. We really
have to go to the scriptures and depend
on a thus sayaith the Lord.
>> Uh, there is no record in the Bible that
says when you see certain numbers, it
can mean something. So, we have to be
careful with this. I've heard different
people say different things. Uh, one
individual was saying that he was a
prophet. uh kept saying things like uh
similar to this. I'm not saying that
you're doing that and uh even watching a
soap opera that somebody said something
in the soap opera. So that means this
and so we have to be careful with these
type of things and ask ourselves um what
is it just a coincidence? You know it
could be because you said you see the
number 11 on a clock. Well the number a
clock has 12 numbers. Why are you
focusing on number 11? Is it because it
was 11:00 in the morning or 11:00 at
night? I'm not sure why that part uh
stands out to you, but uh let's go to uh
the book the Bible in Exodus chapter 26.
Uh we do have a reference to 11. And it
says here, "And you shall make curtains
of goat's hair to be a covering upon the
tabernacle. 11 curtains you shall make."
So this is a as as you look for the
number 11 in the Bible, it's there about
24 times and most of the times there's
really no great significance in the
sense of spiritual guidance for us. Um
for example, the it talks about the 11
disciples uh and it talks about Joseph
having a dream and he saw uh 11 bowing
down to him, but those were his
brothers. But so we have here really no
no clear connection in the Bible to help
us understand that the number 11 is
significant uh for our salvation let's
say uh so because of this people trying
to figure out things some have come to
some conclusions you know you see number
10 oh number 10 there are ten
commandments so the number 10 could
represent the law of god and that's that
seems to be a good conclusion to come
to. Well, what about 11? Well, uh when
you look at 12, it's like the number of
the kingdom. There are 12 disciples, 12
tribes. Uh there are 12 gates. Uh is it
12 gates? 12 gates
>> into the city uh the new Jerusalem. So
that's the number of the kingdom. So
where's where's does 11 stand in this?
So if you look at number 10 represents
the law of God, then some are coming to
the conclusion that 11 does not
represent the law of God and order.
Could it be this order? Could it be
chaos? So, some people are coming to the
conclusion that number 11 is chaos. But
is is that biblical? It could be. But
really, when we look at prophecy,
um it doesn't have special significance
with number 11.
>> When we look at uh salvation, number 11
doesn't have any special significance
for us, any great importance for us.
>> So, uh we have to be careful with these
things. I would say exercise caution.
Take this to the Lord in prayer.
uh for me uh personally as I read the
scriptures. I don't know if Pastor James
want to sh chime in on this, but I don't
see great significance in this
spiritually and in the Bible to to to
say that it's uh something new has to
come or you're going to face chaos or
something like this. Just continue
trusting in the Lord. Face each day
looking unto Jesus.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you very much, Pastor
Denzy. Well, we're going to take a short
break to remind you how you can
participate with 3ABN Today Bible Q&A.
We'll be right back.
If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa at3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
[Music]
Be sure to include your name and where
you live. And then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
Thanks for staying with us. Let's get
some final thoughts from our panelists.
Pastor Denzy, how about you first?
>> Thank you so much. I just want to say
something concerning um hell because
some people think that their relative
may be in hell right now burning and
burning and burning and they will
continue burning without end.
>> Uh this is a a a terrible terrible idea
that is not found in the Bible. Uh so
what we do see in the Bible is Romans
chapter 6 vers 23 which says the wages
of sin is death. That's the punishment
for for sin for wickedness. The wages of
sin is death. So there's really no one
burning in hell right right now and they
will not burn forever and never and
ever. They will perish because the Bible
says that for God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believes in him will not
perish but have everlasting life. So
those that do not believe will perish.
>> Right. Amen. Thank you, sir. All right,
Pastor James, how about you? Final
thoughts.
>> Just a quick uh reference back to one of
the questions on the seven second
comingings of Jesus. Just give the
references. Revelation 17 is the first.
Revelation 6:15-17 is the second.
Revelation 11:14-19 is the third.
Revelation 14:14-20 is the fourth.
Revelation 16:12-15 is the fifth.
Revelation 7 or Revelation 19 111-21 is
the 6th. And Revelation 22:12 is the
seventh.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, thank you. Yes, sir.
>> Uh, I wanted to say that I said Numbers
4, but it's Numbers 33 that talks about
the different movements.
>> Okay. Amen. Amen. Well, thanks for
joining us. I'll leave you with this fun
scripture song from First Peter 3:15.
But sanctify the Lord God in your hearts
and always be ready to give a defense to
everyone who ask you a reason for the
hope that is in you with meekness and
fear. Thanks. God bless.
>> Amen.
[Music]